ils sont déjà épuisés la route a été
longue et périlleuse mais elle ne fait
que commencer ce qui les attend ils ne
savent pas mais ce qu'il laisse derrière
c'est l'enfer
j'ai entendu les tirs je ne croyais pas
que c'était la russie qui avait attaqué
ma ville natale celle où j'ai grandi
dans laquelle où je suis né où mon
enfant est né dans laquelle nous avons
vécu aimé et dans laquelle j'ai laissé
mes parents mes amis mes proches disent
anastasia la russie dit être en guerre
pour venir les sauver il n'y a rien de
moins vrai dit elle
goal com winnipeg les egytiens n'est pas
venu pour protéger vous êtes venus tuer
vous êtes venus tuer des mères des
enfants des retraités
c'est le coeur meurtri de voir sa vie
qui a volé en éclats dans les
bombardements qu'elle est partie avec ce
qui compte encore son chien et son fils
kyrill sous le choc et a priori je sais
que c'est une guerre dit il mais je ne
pensais pas qu'elle allait éclater aussi
vite je me réveille en me demandant s'il
s'agit d'un attentat à la bombe dans
toute l'ukraine
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici qu'ils étaient encore billère
karkhiv est le théâtre de bombardements
de tirs de roquettes et deux frappes de
missiles impitoyable depuis maintenant
trois jours la deuxième ville d'ukraine
a des airs de fin du monde au moins 21
civils ont été tués dans les attaques
karkhiv pourrait bien servir de
répétition générale pour ce qui attend
la capitale du pays
une colonne de chars d'environ 60 km est
en route vers kiev mais elle subit des
retards importants les russes sont à
court de ressources selon le pentagone
le carburant et les rations pour les
troupes leur font défaut
l'armée ukrainienne publie de plus en
plus de vidéos du genre des jeunes
soldats faits prisonniers ou qui se sont
rendus aux forces de l'ukraine ils ont
tous en commun qu'ils disent ne pas
avoir su vers quoi la russie les
envoyait tantôt ils croyaient participé
à un entraînement
tantôt ils étaient convaincus par leur
hiérarchie qu'il serait accueilli en
héros
ainsi on voit un soldat qui appelle sa
mère en russie
[Musique]
peux-tu venir mais des lui demande-t-il
ils peuvent me libérer si tu viens en
personne
ailleurs au pays dans l'est et dans le
sud principalement les combats
s'intensifient aussi mario paul et le
dombass sont assiégées car seule une
ville importante plaie de la crimée est
maintenant passée sous le contrôle des
russes
en ukraine l'effort de guerre et la
faire de tout ce qui reste à une heure
de garde et travailleurs et des citoyens
de la ville ont formé un véritable
barrage humain pour empêcher les chars
russes d'atteindre la centrale nucléaire
de zappos rija la plus grande d'europe
l'homme du match nul je suis
reconnaissant et stupéfait du courage et
de l'héroïsme de nos habitants 10
travailleurs ils sont sortis sans armes
et ont construit une chaîne humaine de
plus d'un kilomètre de long
selon les nations unies plus de 700000
ukrainiens ont déjà quitté leur pays
alors que plus d'un million d'entre eux
sont maintenant déplacer à l'intérieur
pour poste-frontière de crack au viet
les heures qui passent gonflent les
rangs de ceux qui vont chercher refuge
en pologne c'est au dernier instant
qu'ils ont décidé de partir de tout
laisser derrière dans laquelle vous le
voyez presque que des femmes et des
enfants les hommes eux doivent rester
derrière les quelques zones que l'on
voit sont les vieillards les étrangers
et les pères de famille cela ne viennent
que pour des au revoir remplie de doutes
c'est le cas de rohm and haas qu'il veut
c'est voir son fils la femme ana en
sécurité il peut pas partir mais pour
vous est ce que c'est normal pour moi
sommes de ne pas partir
c'est comme ça qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire il n'a pas l'étoffé d'un soldat de
mai romane mais il fera sa part tana est
ce que votre mari m'a
peut-être au oui oui ça vous inquiète ça
oui
elle ne sait pas si elle retrouvera son
mari mais l'ukraine va l'emporter dit
anna ça elle n'en doute pas ici
marie-eve bédard radio-canada
cracovienne